çok
ama çok teşekkür ederim Öncelikle
davetiniz için Yani ilk kez davet
aldığımda dedim ki ben kimim Yani
kendisi konuşması için diye düşündüm
yani Öcalan değil Burada genelde işte
kendini kanıtlamış bilim insanları
sanatçılar gazeteciler davet ediyor ve
an kendimi Hala
kendi gitmesi gereken upuzun yolun
başında bir insan olarak görüyorum sonra
düşündüm Hani bu konuşmayı Ne üzerine
yapabilirim nelerden bahsedebilirim diye
Kısacası üç tane hikaye anlatacağım
kendi hayatını alakalı birkaç gün sonra
33 yaşıma basacağım ve beni be beni ben
yapmış olan üç tane dönüm noktası var
düşündüğüm zaman eminim aranızda
bilenleriniz olmuştur siloxan efsanevi
bir konuşması var Ben fırça diploma
töreninde yaptığı bir konuşma size bugün
hayatımla ilgili üç hikaye anlatacağım
diye başlar bana e bu kameranın
hikayelerden biri olduğu için büyük süre
kendime üç kere anlatmak istedim ilham
olması onun
izlemediyseniz o konuşma ile yıldızlı
ilk dönüm noktan Ben üç yaşındayken
gerçekleşiyor herhangi bir çocuk gibi
orta kulak iltihabı geçiriyorum çocuklar
arasında çok yaygın bir hastalıktır
bilirsiniz Annem alınırsa hiçbir problem
olmaz çocuklar iyileşti hayatlarının Ona
bir şekilde devam ederler benim
hikayemde ise bu orta kulak iltihabı
maalesef önemli anlamadığı için mi Bir
profesörün de ima Karlı yüzünden iç
kulak iltihabına Oradan da ileri
derecede işitme kaybına yol açıyor Öyle
ki bir gün anaokulunda öğretmenlerinden
biri annem diyor ki
bu kızın Yani bir işitmesine ölçtürün
Çünkü seslendiğimizde duymuyorum
diyorlar Sonuç olarak Onkoloji bölümüne
görünüyorum ve Evet yoğun bir işitme
kaybı başlamış ameliyat olmam gerekiyor
sonrasında işitme cihazı kullanmam
gerekiyor Bu süreçte bu acılı bir
süreçti tam belasını toplamda üç tane
ameliyat oldum sonuncusu koklear implant
ameliyatıyla
iç kulaktaki salyangoz un içerisinde
sinirli ha vardır ve Aslında beyne giden
ve nelerdir onlar Dolayısıyla onlar
tamamen zarar gördüğü için işitme cihazı
olmadan hiçbir şey duymayan ve duymadığı
için de konuşması hızla yaşıtlarına göre
geri kalan ilerlemeyen bir çocuk düşünün
çoğu insan Binnaz bana hala böyle sonra
geliyor konuşmakla duymanın Ne alakası
var derler ama duymadan konuşma becerisi
geliştirmek imkansız bir şeydir o neşeli
arkadaşlar da işitme kaybı yaşayan
çocukların düzgün konuşması ve iyi bir
diksiyona sahip olması mümkün değildir
aslına bakarsanız şimdi eğer bu
kızlardan böyle bozuk dükkanda
konuşuyorum sana Cevabınızı almış
olduğunuz
buz gelir misin tekrar Tamam anne
bu deyimiyle
normal bir okula gidip yaşıtlarıyla aynı
eğitimi alabilecek mi konuşabilecek mi
diye endişelenmeye bir kız çocuğun var
ve İşin kötüsü önünde hiç iyi örnekte
yoktu Yani
benim bu hastalığı geçelim dönemde Oklar
internet ameliyatı Henüz yeni yeni
yapılmaya başlanmıştı ben ilk olanlardan
biriydi O yüzden kendimi çok şanslı
görüyorum Gerçekten çünkü hayatım Şu an
en basit bir şekilde geçirebilir Tamam
bu ameliyat kusursuz bir şekilde
gerçekleştiren doktorların sayesinde
Annem bana hep ben benim mucizemsin da
diyorum ya konuşabilecek mi diye
endişeler yaşarken amonyak saçma
konuşabiliyorum şu anda hayatımdan
şekilde devam etti Biliyorum ve çok
başarılı bir öğrenci oldu motor çoklu
birincilikle bitirmiştim Sonuçta Fransız
Lisesi'ni kazandım vesaire bunları Böyle
çok kolay şeylermiş gibi anlatıyor mu
Yani herhalde 3 ve 13 yaşları arasında
bu On senede Hayatımda hiç çalışmadım
kadar çalışmış mıdır annemin desteği bu
sebeple çok büyük burada bu süreçte Ben
ilkokula giderken bir yandan düzenli
olarak o dolu ondan konuşma terapileri
alıyorum ve sonunda bana dediler ki
Tamam artık gelmesine gerek yok MR
bildiğimiz her şey verdik bak abi
gelmesin dediler ama annem o zaman bile
dedi ki hani Yok daha iyi Konuşabiliriz
de bence daha iyi konuşabilir diye bir
tiyatrocudan diksiyon dersleri
ayarlamıştım O zaman ben ortaokul lise
sınavına hazırlanırken 2014'te de devam
ediyorum Sonuç olarak benim beğendiğim
oluşturan en büyük olaylardan biri buydu
be Hakikaten o zaman hani o küçücük
kızar teşekkür etmek istiyorum pes
etmediği için Çünkü mesela şu anda böyle
bir durum yaşasam normal İşletmesi olan
bir birey olarak kaza geçirip işitme
kaybı yaşayabilirim o zaman hani bu
kadar kararlı bu kadar disiplinli bu
kadar hedefe yönelik hareket edebilir
miydi mi hiç bilmiyorum açıkçası oynama
küçük bir de ayran Beni bugüne geçirdiği
için de teşekkür ediyorum Budan
Sen
benim aldığım dar şey pes etmemek böyle
bir tarif istedik yanlış başıma gidip
uğraşmamak da olabilir bu seçenekte Ama
ben gerçekten çok uğraşmıştım yani bunu
aşabilmek için Ve şunu da eklemek
isterim hani bu probleme sahip olan
çocuklar eğer aileleri ilgisizse
konuşamıyor biliyorlar gerçekten işaret
dili öğrenmek zorunda kalabiliyorlar
buradan benim çıkardığım ders bu
talihsizlik benim başıma neden geldi
diye düşünmektense Evet bu benim başıma
geldi Kabul ediyorum şimdi önümüze
bakalım duruma üzülmektense sorunları
çözmeye yönelik de alıyorum diye
düşünmek oldu yani bakış açınızı
değiştirmeniz gerekiyor ki her şey
değilsin hayatında
hayatındaki en büyük anne dolaşması
yaşadıkları mıdır Yani en zor durumlarda
bile en üstesinden gelemem dediğiniz
günlerde bile devam edebileceğiniz asla
unutmayın hoşça geldi geride kalıyor en
Zorlu geçiyor
düşmekten korkmamak gerekiyormuş a kalka
yürümeye öğrenmek gerekiyor şimdi ikinci
kendime gelirim ikinci hikaye Bu benim
kendi ayaklarının üzerinde durmayı
öğrenme Hikayem Aslında bu hikaye 19
yaşında basıyor oraya müthiş bir
kararlılıkla Londra'ya üniversite
okumaya gitti mu Karım bu kadar mı
Öncelikle Annem tarafından şiddetle
karşı çıkıldı çok iyi hatırlıyorum o
zaman Babamın bir işi batılı beslenme
olmuştur Hala tam olarak kapağına bilmiş
değildik maddi olarak ve çok ciddi bir
borcu vardı Babanın işleri ilk için
yurtdışına göndermeyiz demişlerdi çok
çok iyi hatırlıyorum bunu fakat beni
çağır geçmedim aklımda yurtdışında okuma
hayalim vardı Ben seni davidson.com
okuduktan sonra bir yandan bu dik
üniversite sınavına hazırlanıyorum bir
yandan da hayalimdeki okul olan satır
San Martin kalıyor Kalkan bir tane
girmek için motif oluyor buluşturalım
dünyadaki en iyi tasarım okullarından
biridir gerçekten çok büyük bir hayal
benim için ve kazanması çok zor boku da
herkes diyordu ki yani büyük ihtimalle
giremezsin O yüzden de bir yandan İşte
bu da Üniversitesi'nden hazırlanıyordum
ki onu da oraya kazanamazsam Bu da bir
yere gidebilirim diye bu Eh Bu arada beş
senelik lise hayatım boyunca hapları
sadece iki saat İngilizce dersi
görüyoruz Şükran Sen iştesin değil mi
Benim İngilizcem korkunç sayısını ve bir
yandan İngilizce'de sınavında ne geçmem
lazım Sonuç olarak mi S3 ve lise sonda
müthiş yoğun bir şekilde çalışmam
sonuçlar ben oraya gitmeye hak kazandım
dil sınavında en düşük puanla geçen ama
geçtim ya bilinç şimdi tarihinde Hangi
parayla gittiğimde salaksın da babam
hala başım geçer Bir de senin okulun
içinde bol çaldılar ama Ne yaptıysak
geri dönüşü hep iyi oldu diye ekran Yani
en büyük yatırım hep çocuklara yapmanın
önemli olduğunu Farklı olan bir anne
babayla uyudum tekrar söylüyorum çok
şanslıydım bu olmayabilir Ben toplu
kazansanda gelemeyebilirim Şimdi şöyle
bir genç kız düşünün Türk kahvesi
yapmayı bilmiyorum hayatı boyunca yemek
yapmamış çamaşırı kalmamış yatağını bile
toplanmış ve genç kız bunları söylerken
utanıyorum ama gerçek bu gerçekten içtim
yapmayı bilmiyor bu ve tanımadığım bir
yerde tek başına yaşamaya gitmeye karar
vermiştim
Çok iyi hatırlıyorum Hatta bana giderken
bir miktar para vermiş O parayı da işte
bankaya yatır diye Ben sadece
banka hesabı nasıl açacağım ben bir
üründür abim ağladığımız yerim Yani hala
daha güçlü dalgasını geçer yani Banka
hesabı açma
Yani doğru şey değildi ama benim için
doğdu yani o zaman bu tarz böyle küçük
şeyler yapmak ne Neyse
peki neden o konforlu hayattan çıkıp
böyle bir Zorlu yaptım kendime hala
çalışıyorum Aslında kendimi Ama 17 ve 18
yaşlarındayken bir farkındalık yaşadığım
hatırlıyorum Demiştim ki çok fazla
aileme Bağımlıyım ne Bu iyi bir şey
değil Tabi benim durumum biraz istisnayı
işitme kaybı yaşamış olmanın getirdiği
bir şeydi Bir yandan ama bana artık
küçük bir çocuk değilim büyüdüm ve kendi
ayaklarımın için var yani bunu kendime
kanıtlamak gerekiyor tek başına bir
şeyler üstesinden gelebileceği mi
kendimi kanıtlamak gerekiyor diye kendi
kendime Takip ettiğim çok iyi
hatırlıyorum o noktada şunu hatırlamanı
isterim Sonuçta bir engelli olarak bu
işitme cihazı olmadan Bana hayatına
devam edemiyorum Yani normal şekilde
devam ediyorum Örneğin geceleri içme
cadının çıkartıyorum hiçbir şey
duymuyorum ve deliksiz uyurum o ama
şöyle durumlarda oluyorum sana ben
uyurken gece eve hırsız girdi böyle
şeyler yaşadım ve Yani evden bayağı işe
gitti falan Ben hiçbir şeyin farkında
değilim veya işte bir başka olay mesela
tatile gidiyorum tatile giderken yolda
cihazın bozuldu ve ben birkaç gün hiçbir
ses duymadan geçirdim yani İnsanlarla
iletişim kuramadım hala Mesela bir
kuaföre gitmek beni şimdi stres
kaynağıdır Çünkü bırakıp çıkıyor içme
Cadı çıkıyor Ben hiçbir şey bilmiyorum
bildiğim bir yere gitmeyi tercih ederim
hep oyundan Çünkü bir şey söyleyeyim Ben
anlamıyorum bu gibi şeyler yüzünden
insan o kendi ailemize elbisesini tahmin
edersiniz beni yalnız bırakma ekmek
içleri a vermiyordu Bir de dondurma
hiçbir tanıdıkları Yok ya Başıma bir şey
gelse de arayabilecekler kimse yaptım
Dolayısıyla onların bu kararını
desteklemeleri çok büyük bir adım da
onlar için de Daha sonrasında ben
bunlardan mezun oldum Tabii çok basit
bir şeymiş gibi anlatıyorum Gene olmadı
ama çektiğim daldıkları Gerçekten
biliyorum ama bütün o yaşadığım
zorluklar Beni bugünkü Ben yapmıştır Ben
kendime yerleştirmiştir müthiş bir
özgüven kazanmışım dhroröş arıyorum
sayesinde buradan öğrendiğimde aşağıda
şu aslında kendi Konfor alanının dışına
çıktığınız zaman yani ile ilgili müthiş
farkındalıkla kız olsun ben başka
yönlerini keşfe diyorsun kendine alakalı
17 yaşında bu böyle gitmez kendini
zorlama mısın en iyi okul kazanmalısın
yurtdışına tek başına yaşamalısınız
diğer sesi dinlediğin için gene kendime
teşekkür ediyorum Bir tane daha çıktı
Bunu yapmasaydım büyük ihtimalle O
konforundan çok sonra çıkacak herkes
çıkacaktım ben çok geç olgunlaşır
akmasında ve Hayır yapamazsın Hayır
gidemezsin diyen tüm seslere rağmen
onları kullanmamızı kapayıp inancımızı
ve umudunuzu kaybetmeyin hedefiniz için
canla başla çalışmak gerekiyor Ben de
annemi dinleseydim bir de aslında dediği
zaman başka kaybetmiştim Ama dinlemedim
çok çalıştım çok uğraştım ve bir şekilde
her şey rayına oturdu Aslında
şimdi hikayeme gelelim 2017 yılında
YouTube kanalımı açmam da başlayan bir
hikaye Bu tamamen bir hobi bir heves
olarak başladı ve dört sene sonrasında
mü 81 kişiye ulaşan bir platforma
dönüştü kanalı açtım seni olan 2017'deki
çizimini tarif edeyim sizde bu ya şimdi
depresyon out içmeyi ile Çünkü hayattaki
amacını bulmadığın düşünen yaptığı işten
tatmin olmayan Daha doğrusu yetersiz
Duran m a fazla kişiye yardımcı
olmalıyım diye düşünen bir kadın
düşüneyim olduğu yerden mi bu hayat
amacına gram yaklaştığını hissetmiyor
kapana kısılmış hissediyor hapiste gibi
istediğim yani o dönemde benim Git
bakalım merakım başladı ve günde böyle
5-10 dakika kendime bakmak ciddi mamako
depresif halleri geri bırakmam da
yardımcı oldu Çok basit bir şey ya hani
yapmaktan kalkmasını sağlıyor da en
azından o zamanlar benim bir de cilt
bakım cilt bakım konusunda obsesiflik
derecesinde araştırma yapıyordum o
dönemde sürekli makale okudum ok sikten
abarttım düşünmeyin hak eden günde böyle
dört beş altı saatimi bağlan bu konuda
bilgi edinme harcıyorum Hiç sıkılmadan
Sonra dedim ki ya İnsanlar bunları
okumaya bilgileri derlemeye baktı olmaz
seni ben en iyisi Boş zamanlarında
videolar halinde koyayım isteyen
faydalansın çekimden Sonra Hayal
edebileceğimi çok açısından da çok büyük
bir kitleye hitap ediyor durumdayım İşte
bu sadece cilt bakımı konusunda değil
hayata dair birçok konuda kendini ifade
et Bu bir yer oldu YouTube kanalım benim
için ve Evet biliyorum atom parçalanıyor
çok basit gözüken bir iş yapıyorum
Bazıları için Ama şunu birazcık Yani her
gün onlarca kişi lan Çok güzel mesajlar
geliyor yani tanımadığım onlarca insanın
hayatında dokunabiliyorum motive ediyor
olmak beni gerçekten çok güzel müthiş
bir takım duygusu yaşatıyor günün
sonunda Gerçekten insanın sevdiği iş
yapmış kadar güzel bir şey olmaz ve şunu
da ekleyeyim ben bu kanalı Açtıktan
sonraki ilk iki buçuk sene içerisinde
hiç fark aldım
Ama bu sevdiğim için de halı olarak
yaptığım için de çıkmayı düşünmedim
Çünkü yani Ya eminim Benim yerimde
başkası olsam ya Bu kadar emek veriyorum
bu kadar para harcıyorum bu için maddi
olarak karşılığını alamıyorum deyip
bırakabilir de bu gerçek ama ben bu
noktada Hani hayatım bana sordu sunduğu
yollardan devam etmek yerine kendime
yepyeni bir yol açmış olduk bu kanalı
açarak ve çok zor olan Sam daikichi Ne
yapmaktan özellikler beni çok yoksa da
Sonuçta pes etmedim yani iş sesini
dinlediğin için ve daha fazla insana
yardımcı olmalıyım düşüncesiyle Harekete
geçmiş olduğu için buradayım şu anda
Bazen o yüzden kaybolmak İyidir ki ben
de öyle hissediyorum Özellikle bu işe
başladın akşam çok kaybolmuş söylüyorum
hepimiz zaman zaman böyle isteyebiliriz
bulunduğumuz yer iyi algılayabiliriz
Aslında bu kendine yeni bir yol çizmem
gerektiğini bir göstergesidir belki de
en azından benim için öyleydi
yaşadığımız her şey tamam O hayal
kırıklıkları işini de yaşadığınız
zorluklar hepsi size Aslında olmanız
gereken yere bir adım daha taşıyor
diyebilirim Yeter ki alıştık almaya
devam edin yani kendinizle gurur duyun
ne kadar başkasına bir şey kanıtlamak
için değil Siz kendinizle gurur duyana
kadar durmayın Oğuz Umut hep vardır
İnsanın içindeki yan İşte aslında
ilerlemeye çalıştığınızın bir kanıtıdır
yani o sesi dinlemek gerekiyor e e
o kimse görmese bile sizin kendi
kendimizi parlatmaya çalışmamız yani
ilerlemeye çalışmamız gerekiyor Çünkü
kimse sizi sizden daha iyi tanıyamaz
bilemez
ve hiçbir çapında boşa gitmiyor Bunu
unutmayın güzel şeyler genelde zaman
oluyor sabretmeyi öğrenmek gerekiyor Ben
Bu süreçten çok Sabretmeyi öğrendim
açıkçası YouTube kanalı Açtıktan sonraki
ilk bir selam de 1000 takipçi mavi ve
eşime diyordu ki ben 10000 takipçi
göremem ama o 1000 takipçi var o kadar
büyük mutluluk veriyor çünkü ben hiçbir
şekilde motivasyonu kaybetmiyorum Hani o
kadar emek veriyorum bu kadar mı şekilde
asla düşünmedim o bir kişinin mali bile
bana Bana müthiş bir mutluluk veriyordu
şöyle düşünüyorum ya bir kişi aynı odaya
topladığınız Düşünsene de okuyamazsınız
yani kocaman bir salon gerekir O bile
inanılmaz Mutluluk veriyor bana bu çok
büyük bir sayı olarak geliyor yani şu an
geldiğimiz noktadan benim kendi şirketim
var Kendime ait şirket var Ve sonunda
beni tatmin eden bir iş yapmış oldum
Aslında ve bu tamamen kimseden destek
almadan Kendi çabalarım kendi emeklerin
sayesinde oldu Doğan Cüceloğlu'nun çok
güzel bir sözü vardır Evet kulağıma
hepsi olmuştur Bu bir insanı
değerlendirmek için nelere sahip
olmadığına değil ayıp olduklarıyla neler
yaptığına bakın yani başlamak ve
başarmak için çok fazla şey ihtiyacınız
yok elinizdekileri ve sahip olduğu
yetenekleri iyi değerlendirmeyi bilin
Yeter ki çok çalışmış olan hiçbir şey
asla olmuyor ilerliyorsunuz son olarak
da Kendi başınıza güvenin demek
istiyorum Ve sonunda söyleyerek
bitireceğim konuşmamı 33 yaşında bir
kadın olarak yolunda çok başındayım Ben
de hala başaracağım çok şey var parka
kendime yaratacağım yepyeni Yollar ve
bunları yaparken asıl amacım hep
insanlara faydalı olmak olacak çünkü
beni asıl tatmin eden şey o günün
sonunda ve Tabi bunu yaparken de hırstan
sahtelikten uzak öldürme dürüst bir
hayat yaşamak olacak ve onun ölene kadar
hep aç bir öğrenci olacağını biliyorum
hiçbir zaman bana aldım ben tamam
demeyeceğim hep öğrenmeye devam edeceğim
hepimiz için böyle olur bence ve tüm
yolları da Düşe Kalka yürümek için
sabırsızlanıyorum beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]